change is coming to the historic West
Side as the City Works to revitalize the
area one developer is hoping to take it
to new heights the Planning Commission
for the city of Las Vegas will consider
the Harlem Nights hotel and casino
project during Tuesday's meeting our
Laura negretti breaks down the proposal
and what residents are saying
[Music]
a familiar sound that could be happening
in historic West Side the proposed
project is at Jackson Avenue and F
Street Tokyo Casino formerly New Town
Tavern would be torn down and in its
place Harlem Nights hotel and casino a
60-story 680 plus foot tall building
with more than 760 hotel rooms and 450
residential units project consultant
Lisa Mayo derizo says it would be a game
changer for the community it creates
economic development on the historic
west side which needs it developers are
hoping to hit the jackpot on their 700
million dollar project but the Planning
Commission has denied most of the
project because of current Zoning for
example seven stories is the current
maximum height there could be approvals
with conditions we would consider you
know everything that's put in front of
us if they say you know look you've got
to go down you know some floors okay we
would consider that we would look at
that I talked to a neighbor who lives
just down the street here and while
she's excited it would be close she also
questions the location Manuela Williams
has lived here for 17 years the police
came here to my house to subpoena me for
my cameras because they had a murder
right here down the street and then they
had another lady died over here and they
had a shooting right here it's a very
bad area they built the casino I would
love it an opportunity to revitalize a
piece of Vegas rich in black history and
culture in Las Vegas Lauren negretti 8
News Now
the planning commissions hearing is one
of the first steps the city council gets
the final word possibly in May